hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the 1970 Palma de Majorca inter-zonal
tournament here Bobby Fischer faces
another Czechoslovakian Grandmaster it's
a last team award although although
today court is is a German Grandmaster
in those days he represented
Czechoslovakia he represented it in
eleven chess olympiad and then later
when he got German citizenship he
represented Germany three times in the
chest Olympia and he will be an even
tougher customer for Bobby then Miroslav
Phillip also checks luck in Grand Master
who he faced in the previous round you
know you remember that game were Bobby
played b3 and prior to this game Fischer
and Hort played some five games four of
them were drawn and only one game was
won by Bobby but that game was but there
was a blitz game in hair technology so
in classical time format no games were
won by either player so definitely an
important game for both of them and Hort
has the white pieces he opens the game
would be for Bobby plays c5 with the
Sicilian defense as he was known to play
you know it was a normal response for
him against efore Knight to c3 horse
chooses the closed Sicilian d6 Knight to
f3 a 6 g3 preparing to thin cattle the
Bishop Knight to c6 Bishop to g2 Bishop
to g4 by Bobby h3 forcing Bobby to
decide whether he will give up the
bishop pair or go back with the bishop
but this was all Bobby's playing he
plays Bishop captures on f3 allowing
hoard the bishop pair Bishop captures on
f3 and now g6 so this is a pretty
standard trade Hort it now has the
bishop pair but Bobby for his remaining
dark square bishop he will be able to
use this beautiful the dark square
diagonal we have d3 Bishop to g7 and now
a for preventing ball before from
further expanding on the Queen side
would be v e6 we have brush up to g2 and
now Knight G to e7
Hort castles Bobby castles and now
Bishop to e3 and here black has to
figure out some sort of
plan you definitely want to develop your
queen you have to connect your rooks you
know everything one wants to achieve out
of the opening and the black wants to
play Queen to c7 here but it's very
interesting how Bobby goes about this he
doesn't just play Queen to c7 and allow
black and allow her to play whatever he
wants
first he plays the Queen to a5 this
comes with a double attack against the
c3 Knight so if Bishop captures you
would recapture and the Queen would then
win the b-pawn
so here court moves the bishop back
brush up to d2 now threatening some sort
of discoveries and only now the special
move the Queen back Queen to c7 so
instead of just playing Queen to c7
first Bobby as this Bishop is much more
active on e3 then on d2 first you know
making it a less active and only then
bringing in the Queen to c7 so now if
white wanted to play Bishop to e3 now he
would basically just lose the tempo and
it would be like Bobby got a free move
for the Queen and now it's again Bobby's
move so after Queen to c7 a very nice
maneuver Queen to be one now we have
nice to d4 and now a5 and now this a5
does grab a lot of space on the Queen
side and if you could somehow get this
nice to a4 to b6 and that would be very
nice but Fischer doesn't allow it he
plays Knight to c6 now Knight to f4 of
course will be met with Knight captures
as now there is a double double attack
against the f5 pawn we have 91 opening
up
I discovered defense from the bishop
towards the a5 pawn and c4 pawn a c4 now
a very nice pawn move by Bobby that
really allows him to activate his pieces
we have D captures on c4 and now Knight
to d5 93 5 a very nice move threatening
to capture back the pawn and there is no
way for black for white to defend this
pawn I fear if you even react this in
some way nice to e3 doesn't really
matter be three you would you will lose
a piece here with nice to f3 let's say
even play something like a knight to III
in knight of three check check the King
and you lose the bishop on b2 so here at
Bishop to e3 was played getting the
out of that nasty D to square me it's
very interesting that this Bishop wasn't
d2 only because Bobby played that Queen
to a5 back to c7 move but okay Knight
captures on c4 now we have rook to a
four and now comes a rook to c8 Bishop
captures on d4 Bishop captures on d4 and
Queen to a 2 now I would a double attack
on the c4 Knight and here Bobby wants to
get rid of the bishop on d4 as the night
for for the time being cannot move as
the rook would be attacking the bishop
so you could play something like Bishop
days to a7 if you want to keep an eye on
the King side but Bobby plays Bishop to
f6 and he wants to keep an eye on the
Queen side c3 now and now again it's
very interesting how Bobby takes care of
things on the Queen side the a5 pawn is
defended nicely the c3 pawn now that
hotplate c3 it's no longer a target the
bishop is no longer I am the b2 point so
all is well here so what what did Bobby
play here here in Bochum played Bishop
to d8 and now creating a triple attack
against the a 5 point the only way to
defend dfi point is to play b4 and while
you have defenders D a 5 point here now
you've created a weak c3 pawn now you
see that Bob is night is blockading this
pawn and now Bobby will once again
attack the c3 pawn so that's a nice
thing to remember if there's a backwards
pawn you want to attack first you block
a tit you don't allow it to be pushed
forward and then you attack it the
bishop back to f6 now piling up on the
c3 pawn rook to e1 we have rook F to d8
and now Queen to e2
King to g7 we have roped back to a2 and
the now comes h5 [ __ ] place h4 Queen to
d7 and now King to h2 we have Knight to
e5 rope the C to defend preparing to the
further defend the c3 pawn a Knight to
g4 with check King to h1 and rook to c7
now bob is ready to double up on the C
file Bishop to h3 and here Bobby doesn't
allow pieces to be exchanged so night
back to e8
preparing to bring the knight back
all the way to C 492 III and now Queen
to a for not allowing her to push the c4
pawn because the Queen would then be
attacking the b4 phone so first court
brings the other look to be one now he
is ready to put the c4 pawn but Bobbie
doesn't allow it Knight back to c4 we
have rope to 82 attacking the Queen and
Queen back to c6 Knight captures Queen
captures Queen captures rook captures so
Hart was able to exchange Queens but
still now there is a route blockading
this c3 pawn and also the pawn is on a
dark square so Fischer can attack this
point with three pieces with both rooks
and the bishop but horde can only defend
it with the two rooks as he does have a
light square bishop so we have b5 first
here there's no way to defend the c3
pawn we have Bishop captures on c3 pawn
captures on e6 pawn captures on a6 and
now look to b6 attacking the a sex pawn
Fischer captures on e4 we have rook
captures an a6 and now rook to e1 check
King 2h to d5 now we have looked at the
rook to c6 and now rook to a-1 forcing a
trade of rooks row captures the Bishop
captures and now a six so if you look at
this position it is an opposite colored
Bishop endgame so you know usually this
you know positions like end games like
these would be a draw but here Fischer
is up upon but not only that fisheries
up upon also Fischer has one point
island and our heart has two point
islands so okay
butter up to d4 first attack in DF to
pawn but also not allowing this point to
be pushed any further so we have rook to
c2 and now comes King to f6
we have f4 and rook to b8 it's very
interesting that the a6 pawn would queen
and a light square if it was ever able
to get so far and while horse does have
a light square bishop which could kind
of help escort it all the way to eight
Fischer has a pawn on d5 and
you know things like this will not be
possible
rook to a - you have to put a rock
behind a passed pawn that's the rule
Bishop to e7 not allowing the pond to be
pushed to a dark square we have Bishop
to f1 and now King to e7 so here it's
not all that easy to make any progress
with black but Fischer you know will
make an attempt making the room for this
pawn now f6 and d5 is coming Fischer
wants to create two connected past
points in the center of the board
kingi - we have king to d6 now Bishop to
d3 and now rook to b3 attacking the
bishop
Bushra back to e2 and the now comes f6
preparing a5 rock to d2 rook to a3 now
find that a sex pawn Bishop to d3 and
now Bishop to e3 rook to d1 and now rope
to a two with Czech king of three and
now Russia back to d4 we have G for Luke
to the rook to a3 as the bishop now
cannot move now if I followed by e4
would be deadly King to g2 now the
bishop is able to move we have Bishop to
e3 attacking the f4 pawn and now King
back to f3 Fischer moves it back to c5
and now we have King to g3e five now
preparing efore attacking the pin piece
F captures only for F captures on e4 and
now King to g2 you cannot allow me for
to come with an attack on the bishop
while the bishop is pinned H capture son
g4 and now Bishop captures on g6 rook
captures on a6 now Fischer is up two
points King to g3 and now King to e6 h
h5 with Bishop to e3 King captures on g4
and now rook to a for a would check King
to f3 and now but should be back to a
special back to h6 and not allowing this
point to be pushed
anywhere further rook to be won and now
comes Eve or with check King moves now
comes rook to a3 with check King to g4
and now King to e5 hiding the king on a
nice dark square root to b8
we have rook to e1 rook to
with Chuck King to d4 and now King to f5
Roop to f1 would check King moves to e6
and here after Bobby played III last in
elastomer Hort resigned the game why did
he resign he resigned because there's
really no plan here for white you have
to play something e 2 is coming followed
by e e won promotion to a queen once you
move to once you move the king simply
look to f2 you can prepare bringing your
point - e - there's no way to prevent it
with your light square Bishop and after
white place anything is there really
isn't a good move here for white
whatever you play E - is coming and then
again whatever you play Bishop to e3
will block the rooks attack against the
the e pawn and it's all over whatever
you play a 1 is coming and it's all over
so that's again from round 5 elastin
court vs. Bobby Fischer a very nice
victory for Bobby Fischer of his first
victory in classical time format against
last imil court so very nice achievement
again only one row to start with and
then four consecutive wins in a row in
in a row it's a it's a very nice
tournament for Bobby Fischer so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you're enjoying this coverage
of the 1971 with America Interzone
tournament so far as usual you can check
- all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
with a game from round 6 were Bobby
faces his old nemesis Samuel Reshevsky
thank you all and I will see you soon